dans touche pas à mon poste avec ton
groupe
on a une semaine de roland garros j'ai
chaud c'est chaud là j'irai là on est là
on va faire un jeu tout sommes regardés
ils sont tous en tenue de sport par ils
sont beaux ils sont beaux ils sont
magnifiques
bon alors on s'arrête très simple jeu le
jeu c'est très simple regardez les
chéris il ya là bien là ma chérie elle a
pas compris que céline valérie damidot
et vous allez tout servir on va tout
servir des mêmes on arrive à servir le
plus rapide en ligne aura celui qui
passera toutes les missions avec la
perruque d'agassi oui mais demandent pas
de viser là mais non mais c'est pas
possible c'est toi quel point nos
martyrs plusieurs lui mais c'était bien
c'était ton père isabelle 25 à les
attentions à l'ennemi
attention
mais ça a été non mais c'est bon j'ai
même techniquement c'est bien attention
je voulais thierry jamais fait tennis de
ma vie alors allez-y
non ça fait il aura aussi à aller vite
vite et moi je ne sais pas faire tomber
moi je vous propose un truc si je fais
plus de 80 ans c'est matthieu delormeau
quai auquel à kouba gaza allez vas-y tu
peut te coûter sa légèreté mois c'est
trop
[Applaudissements]